un document dans ce journal l'enquète de
nos envoyés spéciaux que 200 paires et
adèle house ou wesh qui ont pu
rencontrer au maillot maroc ahmed
boukhari l'ancien agent des services
secrets marocains qui affirme détenir la
vérité sur l'affairé ben barka un juge
français attend en vain son témoignage
est aujourd'hui à remède pour harry a
été interrogé par la police marocaine
depuis un mois un homme se cache dans
casablanca un ancien agent des services
secrets marocains qui affirment savoir
la vérité sur l'affairé ben barka
cet homme s'appelle ahmed boukhari et
nous l'avons rencontrée dimanche dernier
quelque part dans cette ville
le rendez vous se voulait secret mais
très vite nous sommes pris en filature
par plusieurs hommes en civil en moto et
en voiture
la partie de cache-cache avec la police
va durer une demi-heure
dès que l'on s'arrête pour les filmer
ils font demi tour nous n'arriverons pas
à les semer
et l'interview aura finalement lieu dans
une chambre d'hôtel pourquoi vous parler
aujourd'hui cela fait 36 ans que cette
affaire me pèse sur la conscience donc
plusieurs années j'ai hésité à dire ce
que je sais pas ce que les circonstances
dont le pays ne s'y prêtait pas le 1er
juillet dernier les révélations d'armes
et boukari sur l'affairé ben barka font
l'effet d'une bombe au maroc dans le
monde
et l'hebdomadaire marocain le journal il
donne le nom des assassins est décrit
dans le détail l'enlèvement de ben barka
en 65 à paris
de permanence au bureau des services
secrets ce jour là à remettre gourari
suit heure par heure ce qui se passe en
france d'enlèvement quartier latin le
transfert dans la ville un
fontenay-le-vicomte l'interrogatoire la
torture et la mort de ben barka qui a
tué ben barka glynis et offrir des deux
le général oufkir un fidèle d'entre les
fidèles d'hassan ii et le commandant
climie un autre militaire deux hommes
qui disparaîtront plus tard dans des
conditions très mystérieuse autant
d'hassan ii tous les gens que vous avez
cités ont démenti on vous traite
aujourd'hui de menteur d'affabulateur
c'est faux ce sont ces gens là qui sont
les des grands menteurs et des assassins
vous avez envie aujourd'hui d'être
entendu par le juge français
oui j'ai une grande envie d'être entendu
je sais que la vérité va éclater tout
dépend de cet entretien vous avez peur
aujourd'hui pour votre vie oui j'avais
vécu pendant très longtemps dans les
services secrets marocains dans les
services spéciaux et vous avez vous
aussi sûrement peut-être fait des
filatures traquer des gens guen vie des
gens oui on a fait des filatures on
enlevait des gens ont d'abord tiré des
urnes et aujourd'hui vous vous trouvez
de l'autre côté jeunes trouvent de
l'autre côté de la barrière et vous
savez peut-être ce qui peut se passer
ce que vous arrivez au 8 juillet attend
d'elle qu'est ce qui peut vous ait
assassiné facilement d'ailleurs il ya 17
jours
ma famille est victime d'un accident
mystérieux agissent devant chez moi
dans son interview à remède beaux arts
ea nous a confié qu'il avait l'intention
de poursuivre ces révélations sur tous
les dossiers noirs de l'histoire du
maroc
les enlèvements de dirigeants syndicaux
politiques les disparitions et les
tortues
dès la sortie de l'hôtel nous retrouvons
nos accompagnateurs
après une nouvelle demi heure de cache
cache avec la police
nous abandonnons finalement armelle
gourari en plein centre ville
il est évidemment impossible pour nous
de savoir si arm êtes-vous rary dit
toute la vérité
seul un juge d'instruction avec de réels
moyens d'investigation peut vérifier
point par point son témoignage à
remettre gourari aujourd'hui n'attend
qu'une seule chose que les autorités
marocaines lui renouvelle son passeport
afin qu'ils puissent se rendre à paris
et témoigne officiellement devant le
juge français chargé de l'enquêté sur
l'affairé ben barka